>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Georgette Dorn: It is a real
pleasure to welcome Hugo Medrano,
the Director of Gala Hispanic
Theatre, a real pioneer
in the arts in Washington.
And he will introduce
our wonderful playwright
who wrote the play that's being
premiered this week at Gala Theatre.
Hugo Medrano.
[ Applause ]
>> Hugo Medrano: Thank you very much
Georgette for your presentation.
I am so pleased to present in
the name of Gala Hispanic Theatre
in Washington D.C. the
presence and the work
of this magnificent playwright from
Cataluña, Spain, Jordi Casanovas.
It was a pleasure for Gala to invite
him to write a particular play
that deals with Cervantes,
Miguel de Cervantes Saavedra,
the famous author from Spain.
Cervantes was the creator of
course of Don Quijote de la Mancha.
And we kind of commissioned
Casanovas to create a play
that in commemoration of the
400 years of Cervantes death.
I think it was a good way for Gala
to really celebrate the
great playwright novelist,
the first novelist that has
been kind of not ignored
but let it pass during
all these years.
He wrote many plays, he wrote
many novels, novelas ejemplares,
but his most important work
was Don Quijote de la Mancha.
Let me tell you something,
I was kind of scared
when I commissioned this work.
Because we were kind of thinking,
well maybe Casanovas start
to do laudatory play about
Cervantes, a very academic,
a very kind of homage, very
formal homage, and everything,
because after all he is
a very good Spaniard,
and a very good playwright.
But when he gave me the first
draft, I was completely shocked,
because it was a wonderful
play about a human being.
Very simple and complicated,
and immensely important
analysis of a human being.
Simple human being.
It was a wonderful bridge to get
into the world of this author.
Because we do not know
very much about Cervantes.
And some of the things that we know
about him are not true, are gossip.
And basically this novel although is
a fable, is fantastic in many ways,
but based in real facts
of in his life.
It creates a very very passionate
approximation to this human being.
I urge you to come to Gala
Hispanic Theatre to see this play.
Not because I am the producing
director of the theatre,
but truly because is something
than you are going to learn
about men, about humanity.
He is a very well known
playwright in Spain.
He has right now have three or four
plays already, in different parts
of Spain, and in Chile, in Argentina
too you have a play running.
All successfully running.
So when we commissioned him,
we knew what we were doing.
I hope that he will explain to
you what he did with this play.
And maybe you could
ask him questions too,
either about Cervantes,
either about his writing.
He is a very very open
person for questions.
He loves questions too.
So I give you Casanovas.
[ Applause ]
>> Jordi Casanovas:
Bueno, thank you so much.
Muchas gracias por estar aquí.
Voy a dar la charla en español.
Espero que todos comprendan.
Si hay alguna cosa
que se pierda, pues,
espero poder repetir
y contárselo mejor.
Nada, muy contento, muy feliz de
estar aquí y de estar inmerso en
este proyecto que como
nos contaba ahora Hugo.
Este proyecto que nació del
Gala, de esta idea de celebrar,
de conmemorar, este cuarto
centenario de la muerte de Miguel de
Cervantes, pero con alguna cosa
distinta a lo que se estaba
haciendo, no.
Y claro lo que nos planteamos
desde buen principio,
es que bueno conocemos
muy bien su obra,
pero su biografía aunque hay varias,
está llena de puntos oscuros,
de puntos ciegos y a veces no
lo conocemos lo suficiente, no.
En el caso de España y supongo
que en el resto del mundo, es un,
la vida de este autor
nos es un poco ajena.
Y queríamos como jugar
a enamorarnos de él, no.
Y también a preguntarnos de quien se
había enamorado el mismo Cervantes,
no.
Por eso el título de la charla hoy
era Cervantes Enamorado y Nosotros
Enamorado de Cervantes, no.
Porque era, queríamos
conseguir este doble viaje, no.
Descubrir cuáles eran las pasiones
internas que llevaron a un escritor,
bueno a una persona a
convertirse en un escritor.
A ser absolutamente canónico
de referencia, y que,
y cuáles son las circunstancias
de su vida que le convierten en un
personaje del que nos
podemos enamorar.
Por eso yo quiero contar como
dos bloques especialmente.
Cuáles fueron las preguntas,
los motivos para empezar a escribir
una obra como esta, por un lado.
Y después un poco más concreto
en el proceso dramatúrgico.
Cuáles han sido las soluciones que
he intentado aplicar sobre la obra
de teatro para conseguir unos
efectos y un viaje principalmente
emocional, porque lo que
queríamos y lo que me gusta a mí,
es que las obras transmitan
emociones.
Que todo nos entre por el
corazón y por el estómago.
Y después que sin darnos
cuenta, nos podamos,
pues quizá hacer una reflexión sobre
lo que era no solamente el mundo de
Cervantes en ese momento
sino lo que es el mundo,
no solo de habla hispana,
sino el mundo del arte y el
mundo del éxito en el o el querer
conquistar el éxito en el mundo de
la creación literaria en este caso
en todo el mundo, no.
Y bueno, por eso yo os quería contar
de con estos dos bloques lo que
había sido el proceso, no.
Claro yo no soy, no era un experto,
no lo soy tampoco ahora,
de Miguel de Cervantes.
De hecho el proyecto llegó,
incluso se barajó la posibilidad de
hacer una dramaturgia sobre alguna
de sus obras de teatro, o de sus
novelas ejemplares, etcétera.
Pero llegamos a la conclusión de
que su vida era muy interesante,
y que se podía trabajar.
Entonces empecé un trabajo de
investigación que de algún modo se
traslada en la obra.
Es decir la misma obra se convierte
en una pequeña investigación,
una búsqueda, de cuáles son los
puntos más oscuros de su vida, no.
Y además uno de los principales
atractivos para afrontar una
dramaturgia sobre su vida,
era precisamente, eso no,
que estaba lleno de
huecos en su vida.
A diferencia de Lope de Vega
que era precisamente, su,
uno de sus rivales que tenemos
prácticamente pues los detalles de
toda su vida, en el
caso de Cervantes no.
Y de hecho la obra empieza,
él relatándose en el prólogo
de las novelas ejemplares,
relatando su cara, su rostro,
porque no existe ningún cuadro
que esté comprobado que sea de él.
Es decir, así como en el caso de
Lope de Vega pues había multitud o
había mucho, hay muchos registros,
en el caso de Cervantes, no.
Es decir que es, era una figura muy
muy atractiva para construir una
ficción, porque hay muchas
cosas que no se saben,
y que me he permitido pues
conjeturar, o incluso inventar, no.
Y basé la construcción de la obra en
cuatro preguntas especialmente, no.
Primera, una que me
sorprende a mí como escritor,
y creo que sorprende
a todo el mundo, no.
Como es posible, no,
que un hombre que, ha,
constantemente ha fracasado porque
sus primeras obras no tuvieron
éxito, sus novelas no tuvieron las,
se vendieron lo que
él podía esperar.
Es decir no, tuvo fracasos
en cuestiones literarias.
Tuvo fracasos en el amor.
Pasó por la batalla de Lepanto,
fue herido, cautiverio en Argel,
cinco años después
prisión dos veces,
después de trabajar como comisario.
Es decir su vida era un poco,
fue un poco un desastre.
Tuvo muchos problemas.
No se le conoce, una
historia de amor verdadero.
Y claro, te preguntas, ¿cómo es
posible que una persona que ha
vivido tanta desdicha,
al final pueda escribir?
Al final porque ya tenía
65, 60, 60 y algo años,
cuando escribió el
Quijote, como, 57 perdón,
65 después, a la segunda parte.
¿Cómo es posible que, que ya en
un momento en que autores como
Shakespeare, ya se habían retirado a
esa edad, él retomara su escritura?
Y lo hiciera con la obra que después
se convertiría en una obra maestra,
llena de humor, de esperanza,
de ironía y tan humana
como es Don Quijote.
¿Cómo es posible?
Alguien aparentemente tan
torturado por la vida que,
que después pueda escribir esto.
Esta era una de las,
era la primera pregunta.
La segunda pregunta
era quien fue Catalina.
Catalina es, era su mujer.
Con la que se llevaban
veinte años de diferencia.
Se casó con ella cuando
tenía cuarenta y pocos años.
Y su relación aparentemente
no fue muy buena.
No pudieron tener hijos,
y de hecho lo más curioso,
es que ningún prólogo, en ningún
texto habla nunca de ella.
Es decir, después de más de treinta
años de convivencia no tiene,
no hay, no hay constancia en ningún
texto de él de ese personaje,
no, de esa persona.
Y claro era también una pregunta muy
interesante, preguntarse porque la,
su mujer no aparece en ningún sitio,
porque incluso en los prólogos
pues habla de compañeros,
de otros escritores, de gente que
conoce, pero, de sus hermanas.
Incluso sus hermanas también están
simbolizadas en algunos de los
personajes que salen en sus obras,
pero nada de su, sobre mujer.
Esta es la segunda pregunta.
¿Quién fue Catalina?
La tercera era, ¿por qué
Cervantes y Lope de Vega,
que en un principio eran amigos,
y así constaba también en
textos que se había, que a,
sonetos y textos laudatorios que se
habían mandado y que se celebraban
mutuamente, ah, se convirtieron en
unos enemigos tan acérrimos, no?
Y conocemos y sabemos de un soneto
terrible de Lope en el que manda
directamente el Quijote,
como dice, a los muladares.
Y después la cuarta pregunta.
¿Quién era la persona que estaba
detrás de la escritura de la falsa
segunda parte del Quijote?
¿Quién era, quien era ese tal
Alonso Fernández de Avellaneda?
Este es el motor principal
de la historia.
De hecho que apareciera
esa segunda parte falsa.
Este, ese Quijote de Avellaneda,
le provocó que Cervantes pues
escribiera en poco más de dos años,
más que en lo que había
escrito durante toda su vida.
Es decir, y además le provocó,
que aunque llevaba como
ocho años retrasándola,
la escritura de esa segunda parte,
que de hecho convierte todo el
Quijote en una obra maestra.
Sin la segunda parte
igual estaría coja.
Es decir, no sé cómo
podríamos analizarlo,
pero todo el viaje se puede
ver sumando las dos partes, no.
Si no hubiera aparecido
esta segunda parte falsa,
hubiera escrito esta
segunda parte auténtica,
por quien estaba detrás que
es un enigma aun por resolver.
Hay muchas teorías alrededor,
pero, no, quien estaba detrás.
Y era, esta era la cuarta
pregunta, que me servía para jugar.
Es decir.
Intentar resolver todas estas
preguntas para un dramaturgo,
pues se convertía en una golosina
para poder jugar y crear una
nueva ficción.
Y entonces lo que hice
es intentar relacionar,
intentar rellenar todos los
huecos, interrelacionando, es,
cada una de las preguntas, no.
Y lo que ha aparecido y bueno espero
que puedan ver también la función
porque así también lo han
creado Oscar de la Fuente,
José Luis y todo el equipo; pues ha
aparecido un, como comentaba Hugo,
un Cervantes, muy humano,
muy imperfecto, muy pasional,
esperanzado, tenaz, pero
muy de carne y hueso, no.
A diferencia de otras, hay otras
obras de teatro muy antiguas, que,
que eran casi panegíricos sobre la,
sobre el personaje de Cervantes,
normal, porque hay momentos en
su vida que pueden ser elevados,
y caracterizados, o definidos
como momentos heroicos.
Tomaban este, esta, esta
dirección de, bueno, pues hacer,
convertir al personaje en un
mito más que en un humano.
Y nuestro trabajo ha sido al
revés, no, de olvidarnos de,
de su parte mitológica y buscar
sus imperfecciones que nos,
que como nosotros nos
convierte en humanos.
Intentando responder cada una de
[ inaudible ]
preguntas, les cuento cual fue
el proceso por el que seguí, no.
A la primera pregunta, ¿Cómo
llegó a escribir el Quijote?
Creo que quizá fue la pregunta
más fácil de responder, no.
Cervantes era un hombre inteligente,
pero que se dejó llevar en muchas
ocasiones por una cierta necesidad
de urgencia por triunfar, no.
Esto se nota en sus
primeras obras de teatro,
en algunas obras de teatro,
en algunas primeras novelas,
que intenta en algunos casos
copiar modelos que ya existen,
pero a la vez romper
con esos modelos.
Es decir, no fueron especialmente
éxito sus primeras obras de teatro.
Él aspiraba, él era
muy, muy seguidor;
le encantaba el teatro
de Lope de Rueda.
Y él soñaba en convertirse
en un dramaturgo,
no, y vivir como dramaturgo.
De hecho era mejor negocio que
podía desarrollar un escritor en
esa época.
Y claro es algo que, también al
descubrir esa pasión frustrada por
el teatro, pues también
me enganchó al principio,
no, de la investigación.
Y me imaginé la sensación que
podía haber sufrido cuando,
cuando apareció alguien
como Lope de Vega.
Lope de Vega que tenía una capacidad
para escribir una cantidad de obras,
que además tenía un éxito
bárbaro entre, entre el público.
Que además tenía una vida muy
agitada con mucho, muchas amantes,
con mucha, muy contradictoria
también.
Y claro aun así se convertía,
en un, como lo llama él,
monstruo de la naturaleza, es
decir un auténtico ídolo de más en
ese momento.
Y Cervantes por el
contrario no tenía ese éxito.
Sus obras, aunque había, aunque
contenían parte de innovación,
no acababan de conquistar
al público.
Y me imaginé que eso a Cervantes
le podía sacar un poco de quicio.
Aun así el mismo Cervantes llegó a
escribir alguna comedia al estilo
de Lope.
Por ejemplo, pero inevitablemente
le daba un final distinto,
impropio de la comedia.
Terminaba en parte, no terminaba
el, la relación de la pareja,
no terminaba en matrimonio.
De hecho lo cambiaba.
Y al darle, yo creo, he
imaginado que al darle este,
estos finales distintos, yo creo
que él intentaba mostrar su voz.
Es decir, en el fondo se sentía
que tenía una voz personal, única,
especial, y que no, por eso no
terminaba de doblegarse al gusto
del público.
Advertí que aquí o intuí que
había un carácter fuerte,
una fuerte autoestima sobre lo que
hacía, al menos en su juventud, no.
Y era una actitud, un carácter sin
duda necesario después de haber
pasado cinco años de
cautiverio en Argel.
Y salir y considerar bueno, no,
voy a dedicarme a ser escritor, no.
Sabemos que él era un
apasionado de la lectura,
especialmente de autores italianos.
Y que tenía como, tenía muchas ganas
de hacer para las letras españolas,
lo que habían hecho otros
autores para las letras italianas.
Es decir, darles un
prestigio, darles una calidad,
que hasta ese momento no tenía.
Pero bueno, alrededor
de los rumores,
que le acechaban mientras
estaba en, cautivo en Argel,
pues precisamente cuando
volvió a España,
no encontró nunca una estabilidad,
un puesto de escribiente,
que le hubiera dado pues una
consistencia económica para poder
seguir escribiendo.
Y a eso se le sumó, pues obviamente
las necesidades económicas,
traer dinero a una casa que además
estaba compartida con sus hermanas,
que también tenían una
suerte un poco desafortunada.
Es decir sus hermanas
aun tenían muchos en,
tenían muchos compromisos
con otros hombres,
pero que los hombres
no cumplían nunca.
Y acababa, acababan por,
siempre hay rumores,
no se sabe si lo hacían
aposta, o para conseguir dinero,
o tenían esta mala suerte.
Pero sin duda no era una casa
que pudiera estar acomodada.
Y, pero después incluso
de casarse con Catalina,
que ella era una mujer de una
familia pues más acomodada,
dejó de escribir durante
muchos años.
Al menos de forma activa y pública.
Se presentaba algún
premio con algún verso,
escribía alguna obra que
guardaba en los cajones.
Pero no parecía que su
actividad fuera muy regular.
Pero, después de trabajar
como comisario,
termina en la cárcel de Sevilla,
preso por un malentendido contable.
Y el mismo lo cuenta, porque
lo cuenta en un prólogo,
que empezó a pensar
en pro del Quijote,
a pensar y a escribir la
historia de Don Quijote.
Y aquí es donde uno
puede hacerse la idea,
o al menos es lo que me gustó
imaginar, o, y que es lo que,
lo que transmitimos en la obra,
que en ese momento ese hombre
ya estaba de vuelta de todo.
Es decir ya había descubierto que
todo en su vida había salido mal.
Y que escribir ya no podía tener
otro sentido para él que el
de divertirse.
Es decir en otras ocasiones
posiblemente estaba escribiendo con
la voluntad de agradar.
Y hay algo posiblemente en
esa escritura de El Quijote,
tan distinta también
al resto de su obra.
Igual algo emparentada con
las novelas ejemplares,
durante y posteriores.
Pero hay algo que es, que
transmite, que empezó a,
volvió a disfrutar
con la literatura.
Que simplemente se, bueno
no simplemente; sino que,
es importante, se estaba
divirtiendo.
Y no, quizás sin una
voluntad de crear escuela,
sin una voluntad de trascender,
sin una voluntad de
convertirse en un éxito.
Pero que paradójicamente
consiguió esas tres cosas.
Esa novela que escribió
desde esa libertad,
lo convirtió en un personaje,
en un escritor de éxito,
en un escritor canónico y esencial
después para literatura universal.
Y bueno para mí esa ha sido
una enseñanza magnífica,
para todos los que luchamos un
poco por escribir y contar algo
interesante en el mundo, no.
Cervantes escribió su obra maestra
años luz de toda su anterior propia
obra, posiblemente con
absoluta despreocupación.
Por el placer de escribir,
por el placer de recuperar los
buenos momentos que las historias y
las letras le habían
hecho pasar como lector.
Se reía como contamos en
ese libro de él mismo,
de sus pensamientos y de sus dogmas.
Y ponía en boca de un loco sus
creencias y los discursos que el
mismo posiblemente había sostenido.
Cervantes se libera en ese momento,
descubre esa ironía que ha
sido su vida y su destino,
y lo transmite en esa novela que
décadas a sus siglos más tarde se
convierte en una referencia obligada
para comprender la novela moderna y
el hombre moderno.
A mí me gusta, yo creo mucho en
esta lectura, y esta filosofía.
Evidentemente insisto es una obra
de teatro, es absoluta ficción.
No tenemos documentación que así
pueda confirmarnos que fuera.
Pero hay algo que creo
que es una buena pista,
una buena enseñanza para
nuestros estos tiempos, no.
De que igual estamos constantemente
intentando conseguir éxito, no,
en además, intentando que sea muy
pronto en nuestra carrera vital, no.
Y alguien que lo consiguió
a los sesenta años, pues,
y en un contexto y una época
tan distinta a la nuestra.
Pues es un hecho muy curioso y un
hecho a tener muy en cuenta, no,
y podríamos seguir pensando que
lo que uno tiene que intentar es
divertirse, conseguir divertirse
en lo que está haciendo,
en este caso en la escritura.
Y que quizás el talento sea
potenciar aquello más personal,
más íntimo.
Aparentemente poco
interesante para los demás,
porque no es lo que está de moda,
pero que en el fondo
apasiona a uno mismo, no.
Y a mí me gusta creer
esto, esto está en la obra.
Pero ha sido un poco
descubrimiento a partir de estas
preguntas alrededor.
La segunda pregunta que nos
planteábamos, ¿quién fue Catalina?,
¿quién fue Catalina en su vida?, y
¿a quién amó Miguel de Cervantes?
En casi todas las obras
de Cervantes, pues bueno,
inevitablemente se filtran
los hechos vividos por él.
Desde el mundo de [inaudible],
La Mancha, Andalucía,
en sus tiempos de comisario,
se pueden ver también en
sus novelas ejemplares,
las vivencias en las luchas contra
los turcos, el cautiverio en Argel.
Hay varias obras alrededor
de ese tema.
El pueblo de Esquivias,
incluso posiblemente que es,
posiblemente sea ese nombre,
a ese pueblo de cuyo
nombre no quiera acordarse,
porque es ese pueblo en el que dejó
de escribir y posiblemente dejó
de amar.
Sus hermanas que se
quedaron solteras,
siempre tras los hombres que no
respondían por los compromisos,
que fueran mujeres fuertes,
y mantuvieron de pie una
casa ante la adversidad.
Y así también lo reflejó Cervantes,
empezó a ser como a Pastora Marcela
que no necesitaba de hombres para
vivir y ser feliz.
Y en su obra maestra sobrevuela
el nombre de una mujer que también
Dulcinea, ya sabemos que no responde
a nadie que podemos relacionar con
su vida.
Que es una mujer idealizada,
imaginada, que imagina,
que Quijote imagina más bella,
más elegante de lo que es.
Pero en ningún texto
aparece nada sobre Catalina,
y bueno les cuento un
poco quien era Catalina.
Catalina era hija de una
familia acomodada de Esquivias,
un pueblo de La Mancha,
muy lejos de Madrid.
Al parecer ella se enamoró
enseguida de Cervantes.
Ella era más joven,
era más joven que él.
Y él acababa de escapar de su
amante, una tabernera de Madrid,
que había dejado embarazada.
Pero esa tabernera pues
había, tenía un marido.
Todo ese asunto le podía deshonrar,
y le podía bloquear más la
posibilidad de conseguir un cargo de
escribiente que es lo que aspiraba,
o conseguir un cargo en América
que también aspiraba a eso si le
deshonraban públicamente.
Por eso se fugó.
Dejó el asunto por cerrar.
Después le chantajearon
por el tema de la hija.
Y se fue a Esquivias.
La viuda de un amigo suyo
le encontró esa mujer,
y al cabo de una semana se
prometían y ya se casaban.
Es decir fue todo muy rápido.
Claro, lo lees y lo descubres,
y dices bueno que extraño, no,
todo este movimiento, esa fuga
de Madrid, ese casarse enseguida,
y después no poder ver que en la
relación con Catalina no dio frutos,
no dio ni hijos, ni dio amor.
Porque Cervantes de hecho tomó la
decisión de coger un trabajo que era
comisario de abastos, que era ir
recaudando dinero por todos los
pueblos de La Mancha y Andalucía.
Andalucía básicamente y que
significaba mucho tiempo fuera de
casa y alejado de su mujer.
Eso por eso también fue un motor
para conjeturar que no había
aparecido el amor en su vida, no.
Porque se pudo enamorar o hubo una
pasión con una mujer pero no intentó
resolverlo sino que se fugó.
Después se casó con
otra mujer, donde,
con quien no apareció la
pasión y también se fugó.
Es decir, en el caso de, supongo,
debía ser una persona que
emocionalmente igual tenía como una
necesidad de mostrarse más fuerte
de lo que era, o no tan sensible,
porque obviamente era
una persona sensible.
Pero bueno se fugó constantemente
de esas situaciones, no.
Y es uno de los motores
también, y es lo que decíamos no,
que Cervantes enamorado no,
irnos preguntando de quien
estaba enamorado, no.
Y un poco la conclusión a que
llegamos, es que su carácter,
su manera de hacer no le permitió
amar en muchas ocasiones, no.
Creo que aparece el amor en
unos momentos de la obra,
pero igual sus obligaciones parece
que no le permitían dar rienda
suelta a esta emoción.
Y en la obra pues el hecho de
no saber mucho de Catalina,
pues nos permite plantearnos y así
lo contamos la posibilidad de que
Catalina de hecho estuviera
esperando algo del escrito
de Miguel.
Sabemos que quedó enamorada
enseguida.
Es decir un hombre mayor,
era un hombre mayor que
ella, pero era un poeta.
Y posiblemente Catalina que venía
de una casa acomodada, pero no muy,
con una educación no muy culta,
pues seguramente se quedó muy
enamorada de ese personaje,
y de su obra, no.
Y nos atrevemos a pensar en esta,
desde la oportunidad que nos da,
o me da la fantasía de la ficción,
que ella de hecho también
y así empieza la obra,
esperaba ansiosa leer esa
segunda parte de El Quijote.
Claro ocho años, después de, también
es otra pregunta que está ahí,
porque un hombre que tiene su
primer éxito a los 57, 58 años,
la segunda parte espera
tanto a escribirla.
Porque pasan ocho años, cuando le
da algún dinero, su primer éxito,
no es para, no le sirve para
retirarse ni mucho menos.
Pero sabe que el público,
los lectores tienen
interés en esos personajes.
Y él no, esperó mucho,
esperó pasar muchos años.
Y por eso quise relacionar el
personaje de Catalina con esa
segunda parte.
Es un personaje al que
tengo especial cariño,
también porque siempre me gusta
[inaudible] y pensar personajes
femeninos fuertes.
Y en este caso Catalina toma
una decisión que bueno que es
determinante en el final.
Si no les importa no se lo cuento.
Toma una decisión que
pone en riesgo los dos,
ella su vida y la vida
de Cervantes, no.
Es decir toma una vida muy
determinada, pero muy arriesgada.
Y también hay algo en esta relación
que es un tema que me interesa
obviamente como escritor, y en el
que fácilmente podía empatizar,
lo duro que es ser la
pareja, el compañero,
o compañera de alguien que a
diario está barruntando ideas,
que está pensando, imaginando que se
queda absorto pues pensando en algo
aparentemente tan absurdo como
la tarea de crear historias.
No deja de ser absurdo esto de
inventar historias pero a la vez
indispensable para sobrevivir.
Pero claro uno lo piensa, y también
piensa es duro saber que la propia
obsesión, que a veces uno se
queda obsesionado en una cena,
en una pieza, en un diálogo;
y todo lo que está alrededor de uno
pues carece de importancia en ese
momento, no.
Y precisamente quizá la propia
imaginación es lo que no tendría
ninguna importancia, no.
Pero te das cuenta que en momentos
te puedes aislar del mundo,
quedarte solo con la fantasía,
y eso tiene ese punto de maravilloso
y ese punto de peligroso, no.
Y sin duda de difícil y de doloroso
para los que están cerca no,
que a veces preguntan que hay.
Y no sabes contestarles o
no sabes acercarte a ellos.
No sé, que era un tema muy
interesante a cerca de nuestra
relación de una persona, una
mujer en este caso con alguien
obsesionado, muy entregado a lo que
le apasionaba que era la escritura.
La tercera pregunta que era
alrededor de la rivalidad entre
Cervantes y Lope.
Pues bueno es sabida, y conocemos
los sonetos que se mandaban.
Conocemos los comentarios de
Cervantes en el propio Quijote
destripando, o criticando
las obras de Lope.
Y pero durante el proceso descubrí
que Lope tenía escrita una obra
llamada Los Cautivos de Argel.
Sabéis que Lope tiene como dos mil y
pico de obras que se le atribuyen o
se creen que son suyas.
Se conservan como 400.
Pero una de ellas es
Los Cautivos de Argel.
Algunos afirman que no
es suya, pero algunos sí.
Y entonces yo me lo
agarré como un tesoro,
para la dramaturgia,
para la historia.
Porque claro Cervantes llevaba
en su historial, en sus espaldas,
haber pasado por ese cautiverio en
Argel y así lo trasladó luego en
obras como Los Tratos de Argel,
Los Baños de Argel, etcétera.
Y la obra de Los Cautivos de
Argel, es prácticamente una copia,
escena por escena, de la
obra de Los Tratos de Argel.
Eso era algo habitual en la época.
Es decir muchos autores de teatro,
pues pillaban el argumento
de otro, y escribían.
Es posible que no fuera motivo
de discusión en ese momento.
Pero en nuestro momento si que
el tema de la autoría es muy
importante, y he jugado a
imaginarlo como si fuera ahora, no.
Y me agencie de ese rumor,
que podría ser obra de Lope.
Que me permitió imaginar un
motivo de profunda enemistad.
De decir Cervantes se da cuenta
de que le ha plagiado la obra.
Y decidí ya, rompe completamente con
la amistad y con la buena relación.
A partir de ahí empezó, empieza a
criticar en sonetos y en prólogos y
en diálogos Don Quijote la
calidad de las obras de Lope.
Este le responde, Lope
le responde la batalla.
Sin duda fue una batalla acarnizada
[ fonético ]
. Muy propia de la época
o quizás del país, no.
Nos lo estábamos preguntando
hace unos minutos.
De hecho en ese momento Quevedo y
Góngora también tenían una batalla
entre ellos que parecía más propia
de una batalla rapera de gallos,
que de los poetas que después fueron
de los más importantes de lo que
sería el siglo de oro, no.
Una pequeña paradoja que en
ese momento se producía y que
podemos revivir.
Otra de las licencias que me permito
en la obra y que tampoco puedo
revelar, es imaginar,
bueno que no puedo contar,
es imaginar que al fin, hubo un
encuentro entre Cervantes y Lope.
Es decir después de
toda su rivalidad,
no sabemos si se encontraron.
De hecho vivían a poco más de cien,
doscientos metros en la misma calle.
Es decir, seguro que si daban
una vuelta por el barrio,
se encontraban.
Pues, bueno me permití la
licencia de imaginar su encuentro.
Y de hecho es una de las escenas que
disfruté más escribiendo, que me,
porque me permite dibujar
pensamientos distintos alrededor de
a la creación, no.
Lo que piensa Cervantes,
lo que piensa Lope.
Un Lope más, que solicita
pues una actividad más febril,
que piensa que se debe
pensar más en el público.
Un Cervantes que cree que el
talento debe salir de lo propio,
y ajeno a lo que pueda
interesar al público.
Y esta batalla que es muy divertida,
que tiene demasiado
genio, que encarna a Lope.
Pues bueno, me encantó hacerla,
porque de algún modo
siempre sientes que estas,
que has pensado o has tenido
pensamientos de uno o de otro, no.
Yo creo que ahí en ese diálogo están
las teorías de ellos sobre lo que
tiene que ser la creación, y también
están las mías, no, mezcladas.
Y bueno alrededor de esto
también uno se pregunta porque de
esas rivalidades.
Porque también están muy
presentes ahora mismo, no.
Ahora nos lo preguntábamos, no.
Quizás muchas ocasiones
consideramos que nuestros países,
o sea en este caso España,
es demasiado pequeño,
y que solo se va a permitir que
triunfe una sola persona, no.
Y cuesta mucho poder convertir este
oficio del escritor o de las artes,
en un gremio, es decir
en un proyecto común.
En la narrativa actual de
hecho sucede lo mismo, no.
Una editora relataba hace unos días
un artículo que es difícil encontrar
ahora mismo un novelista que
recomiende otra novela española que
no tenga más de cuatro siglos.
Ningún compañero va a
recomendar a otro compañero.
Y esto es un poco triste,
porque quizás debían ser los
primeros en trabajar juntos por
mejorar nuestras letras, no.
Y de hecho con el permiso
de Lope y de Cervantes,
así me atrevo a sugerirlo
en su encuentro, no.
Hay algo de que le redime,
y que les hace encontrar.
Y que uno de hecho
cuando ocurre la escena,
aparece la moción de pensar que
ojala fuera así, porque todo,
igual todo funcionaría mejor.
Ya no solo en el mundo de las
letras sino en muchas otras,
muchos otros ámbitos.
Y la cuarta pregunta ya
terminando este bloque,
y después ya [inaudible]
mucho al breve.
¿Quién era Alonso
Fernández de Avellaneda?
¿Quién escribió esa
segunda parte falsa?
Este es uno de los enigmas más
transitados en las letras españolas.
De hecho nadie puede afirmar a una
ciencia cierta quién es el autor.
Hay muchos candidatos.
Desde el propio Lope, pasando
por Juan Blanco de Paz,
un dominico que también
sale en la obra.
Que fue, perdón, es que no se
si van pasando las fotografías,
y digo, voy pasando.
Y un dominico que estuvo
cautivo con él en Argel,
y que aparentemente con el que
tuvieron una rivalidad o una,
un odio muy acusado.
Jerónimo de Pasamonte que era
también un soldado que coincidió en
el, en la Batalla de Lepanto.
Y que, del que aparentemente
se ríe en el propio Quijote,
llamándolo Ginés de
Pasamonte y ridiculizándolo.
Autores como Quevedo,
Mateo Alemán, etcétera,
hay listas que incluso tienen más
de treinta nombres conjeturando el
posible autor de este
Quijote de Avellaneda.
Para mí eso se convirtió
en el motor de la historia.
Es decir Cervantes en la
obra tiene dos misiones.
Relatar todo lo que
nunca contó a su mujer,
porque tienen demasiados secretos
ocultos el uno con el otro.
Y descubrir quién era ese
tal Fernández de Avellaneda,
quien era ese hombre,
ese posible enemigo suyo,
que le había insultado
con esta, con esa obra.
Porque si, como saben, ya solo
el principio de esa segunda parte
falsa; este Quijote de
Avellaneda empieza criticando,
insultando al propio Fernández.
Nos desvela la solución de la obra,
pero esa falsa segunda parte es lo
que me sirve para aunar las tres
preguntas anteriores, y mezclarlas.
Ese es el juego que me ha permitido,
dejando claro que es posiblemente
todo mentira, y absoluta fantasía.
Pero preguntarme por qué no,
podría ser cierto hay alguna
relación entre Catalina, entre Lope,
entre Avellaneda, en y
Cervantes obviamente.
Este es un poco el motor, y el,
y lo que ha unido toda
la pieza de la obra.
A título como muy técnico es el
segundo bloque que os quería contar
de cómo está construida la obra.
Después si podéis venir a verla, yo
creo que podéis disfrutar de ello,
porque también José
Luis lo ha potenciado.
Está construida con un
triple plano narrativo.
Es decir la obra sucede en 1616,
que sucede el día en el que
muere Miguel de Cervantes.
Él ha muerto y un hombre
en la calle borracho,
empieza a discutir con otros
que no saben, no recuerdan,
ni conocen nada de Cervantes.
No era un tipo famoso en ese momento
y posiblemente su muerte pasó un
poco desapercibida.
Y ese hombre que es Martín, dice
que él vivió una peripecia con él,
es decir que él le ayudó
a terminar ese Quijote,
a descubrir quién era
Avellaneda, y quien,
y le ayudo a terminar
el Quijote, no.
El segundo plano narrativo es lo
que cuenta precisamente Martín,
es en la historia en 1614,
es decir dos años antes,
Martín conoce a Cervantes a raíz;
él es el mozo de un librero.
Lleva el libro falso
a casa de Cervantes,
y Cervantes lo que hace es
pedirle que le ayude a encontrar.
Ya un Cervantes mayor
que no estaba muy fuerte.
A encontrar a ese Avellaneda, no.
Y ahí bueno, ahí conjeturan
los posibles enemigos,
van a buscarlos y a enfrentarlos.
La relación entre Martín y Cervantes
se convierte en una historia y un
viaje algo parecido también
al Quijote y a Sancho.
Fue algo, un punto accidental no
porque para mí era importante tener
a alguien que relataba toda la
historia que no era conocido
por nosotros.
Es decir ajeno a la biografía real
de Cervantes y que incluso en un
momento dado podemos pensar pues
igual es mentira todo lo que
cuenta Martín.
Y es también un poco el
juego de la obra de teatro,
no importa si es mentira.
Hemos descubierto unas
facetas de personaje.
Tenemos que atarlo todo,
porque es una obra de teatro,
pero no importa si es
mentira o es verdad, no.
Y lo pasa es que esta relación de,
se fue convirtiendo en algo parecido
a la relación que se produce entre
Quijote y Sancho.
Y el tercer plano es precisamente
lo que cuenta Cervantes a Martín.
Es decir Cervantes sabe que debe
dejar escrito al menos a una
persona, las partes
oscuras de su vida.
Esas preguntas que nos planteábamos,
que me planteaba al principio.
Y que en el proceso de
investigación intento relatar, no.
Y es el mismo Cervantes
relatando a Martín,
desde el cautiverio de Argel,
pasando por su regreso,
el intento de ser dramaturgo,
su fracaso,
los días pasados en la cárcel
de Sevilla y la escritura de
El Quijote.
Entonces preguntas las cuentas,
en teoría Cervantes a Martín y
Martín lo cuenta a una gente de
la calle.
Lo que os decía, no, esta estrategia
de tener a Martín incluso borracho
de buen principio, me permite jugar
a que no sea un narrador muy fiable,
es decir, está en nuestras manos
determinar si es cierto o no.
También en este modelo, a
lo que también estoy jugando
constantemente, en con
dos momentos narrativos.
En ocasiones los personajes
cuentan lo vivido al público,
mientras que en otras ocasiones los
personajes lo viven ante el público.
En la puesta de escena incluso,
José Luis ha añadido un,
otro plano simbólico, no, alegórico
de lo que vive y sufre Cervantes,
voy pasando fotografías que
creo que no van circulando,
de lo que vive y sufre
Cervantes en toda su vida.
Jugando de hecho con los
papeles que a veces son,
se convierten en esperanzas,
en frustraciones,
a veces son obras de
teatro, a veces son cartas.
Es un juego muy bonito que ha
planteado José Luis y que le da
este, que creo que nos da
este otro punto de vista,
otro plano narrativo.
Aquí vemos a Lope y a Cervantes.
Y después también,
haber, para mi es.
Para mí es muy importante utilizar
la narración directa de los
personajes para crear los
mundos que se van a desarrollar.
Como ves el espacio es aparentemente
abstracto, es decir jugamos;
vamos a jugar a muchos
actos temporales,
jugamos con ocho magníficos
intérpretes,
pero que deben ponerse en la piel
de veinticinco personajes distintos.
Y el poder determinar con
una pincelada más narrativa,
rompiendo la cuarta pared.
Lo que me permite es pactar la
convención con el público en cada
ocasión y determinar juntos
que vamos a creer en la
siguiente escena.
Es decir, sale Martín y
dice esto pasando en Argel.
Y todos nosotros pactamos que esas
paredes que hace unos segundos eran
la casa, el interior de
la casa de Cervantes,
se convierten en el exterior, en un,
o en el interior de
los baños de Argel, no.
Así pasamos a creernos
que es en una taberna,
o una prisión simplemente con
el uso de nuestra imaginación.
Es algo que me gusta mucho y creo
que también hemos compartido en
muchas ocasiones también con trabajo
con José Luis, de jugar esta,
este punto de teatralidad, es decir
este pacto con el público de lo que
vamos a imaginar.
Y dos características para
quien también pues guste de la
dramaturgia, y quiera verlo durante
la obra es siempre me gusta trabajar
con dos ideas.
La bola de nieve y
el doble conflicto.
La doble, la bola de nieve es un
concepto que me sirve a mí para
determinar que, o sea cual es un
proceso para que crezca una obra de
teatro, y para que crezca
el drama del personaje.
El personaje toma una decisión
para resolver un conflicto,
que le ha de generar
un conflicto mayor.
Es decir me gusta vertebrar las
historias con protagonistas activos,
que toman decisiones erróneas.
Que se complican, que
amplifican su drama,
y que deban hacer un esfuerzo
después titánico para enmendarlas.
Por ejemplo, Cervantes se encuentra
con la falsa segunda parte.
La buena decisión sería la
de no darle importancia.
Terminar la suya.
El sentido común, no, nos
diría, bueno, me olvido de eso.
Convencerse que puede superarla.
Pero no, lo que hace en la obra,
es perseguir a su autor, no.
Y es esa es una mala decisión que
le genera conflictos nuevos en
ese viaje.
Llevará a más problemas que deberá
resolver al final con unas gotas de
sentido común.
Catalina, incluso, que nota la poca
atención de su marido Cervantes,
y lejos decírselo o dejar claro que
sabe un secreto importante que está
oculto entre ellos dos,
decide construir una trama más
compleja y al fin más dolorosa para
los dos.
Y en muchas escenas, lo que intento
siempre es plantear y bueno si ven
la función pues pueden jugar
a descubrirlo, que hace,
que haya siempre un doble
conflicto para el personaje.
Es decir que siempre en cada escena
tenga que resolver dos cosas.
Por ejemplo cuando Cervantes aspira
a consolidarse en el mundo del
teatro, hay un empresario que no
está interesado en sus obras y tiene
que convencerle para
que ponga la siguiente,
la que acaba de escribir
sobre las tablas, no.
Y a la vez tiene a su amante,
que después sabremos
que está embarazada.
Que esta, se está acercando a él,
que de algún modo le está
pidiendo, que un compromiso.
Le está pidiendo que
ese amor se consolide.
Y Cervantes en ese momento
sabiéndolo o no se encuentra con
dos conflictos.
Uno, conseguir que el empresario
se interese por la obra.
Y otro por resolver o determinar si
tiene o no tiene que quedarse para
siempre con su amante,
con Ana de Villafranca.
Bueno, ya he contado un poco los
dos bloques que quería contar.
Espero que haya sido
un poco entretenido.
Así que nada más hacer
alguna pregunta.
Bueno yo les animo a
obviamente ver la obra.
Contar la obra así igual o contar la
génesis de una obra, pues complejo,
y espero que se hayan
podido a hacer alguna pista.
Espero que si pueden ver la obra,
puedan atar todos los cabos.
Pero si quieren hacer alguna
pregunta, yo encantado de responder.
>> Hugo Medrano: Antes
[ inaudible ]
>> Jordi Casanovas: Si, diga.
>> Hugo Medrano: Me olvidé
anunciarles que también tenemos la
presencia de José Luis Arellano,
que es el director de la obra.
Que está aquí presente, y que tal
vez puedan hacerle preguntas a
él también.
También quiero anunciarles que esta
producción de Gala está hecha en
colaboración con Acción
Sur de Madrid.
Es un grupo con el cual tenemos
una magnífica relación colaborativa
desde hace ya seis años.
Con ellos, a través de ellos,
traemos actores de España que
se integran a nuestra compañía,
diseñadores.
Es una relación muy particular,
que tenemos de hace ya muchos años.
Y que nos ha traído
muchísimos éxitos.
Y quiero agradecer a José
Luis por todo este trabajo.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Jordi Casanovas: Si.
>> Tengo una pregunta.
¿Nunca se ha pensado que
en la segunda parte falsa,
[ inaudible ]
Bacon para
un poquillo de aprecio?
>> Jordi Casanovas: Si, no, bueno.
La anécdota del día es que hoy he
recibido un correo de una mujer
holandesa en la que la
primera frase decía,
deje de decir que Cervantes
escribió Don Quijote,
porque es obra de Francis Bacon.
Y después me; es alucinante,
y además afirma que Francis,
escribió todas las
obras de Shakespeare,
la primera parte de El Quijote, la
segunda parte y también la falsa.
Es alucinante.
O sea que alrededor de este mundo
hay muchas teorías posibles y
podría ser.
Sería extraño.
En todo caso no es una mala
obra El Quijote de Avellaneda.
Pero no es fiel al tono y al
descubrimiento de la primera parte.
En principio da la sensación que no,
no podría ser, pero
no sé, yo no lo sé.
[ Pregunta Inaudible ]
Lo de las fuentes claro,
es inabarcable la cantidad de
estudios que hay para cualquier
momento vital que se
conozca de Cervantes.
Además están accesibles
por Internet.
Y claro una de las ventajas, es que,
al trabajarlo todo en el ordenador,
en digital, pensabas en una palabra,
y las buscabas en uno
de los estudios,
en unas de las novelas, etcétera.
Y fue una investigación así, no,
pues relacionada con las
posibilidades que permite la
búsqueda tan rápida en sus momentos.
El libro de Jordi Gracia,
la invención de la ironía,
creo que se llama, fue una
buena referencia también.
Que es trabajo fantástico de su
vida, pero que está lleno de huecos.
Y da de momentos que dice,
que quizá pasaba esto.
Estas conjeturas son los momentos
más divertidos para poder jugar para
un dramaturgo.
Y la figura de este Cervantes,
pues es esa idea de
fracasa y fracasa mejor.
De la, de que la vida te da lo que,
es decir la vivencia es lo que te
permite contar historias después.
Yo creo que es absolutamente
vigente.
Esto es, y también este
hecho que sea alguien tan,
con una edad avanzada, veterano;
en un momento que todo el mundo se
retiraba del trabajo de escritor.
El retoma, y escribe
su obra maestra.
Yo creo que tiene una
vigencia absoluta,
porque precisamente estamos siempre
obsesionados por el contario.
Conseguir que nuestra obra
maestra lo más antes posible.
Incluso hay una teoría que circula
que las ideas brillantes se tienen
hasta los treinta años.
Y claro es después es retomar
esas ideas, o ir mejorándolas,
pero claro provoca una angustia
vital en todo el mundo que no creo
que sea muy sana.
Y me imagino que no se si tuvo
la idea antes de los treinta,
pero en todo caso a los
sesenta años triunfó.
Y bueno creo que es absolutamente
necesario recuperar este personaje.
[ Pregunta Inaudible ]
>> Jordi Casanovas: Si es curioso,
es posible que la celebración fuera
más potente con el aniversario de El
Quijote con el aniversario de su
autor, de la muerte de su autor.
Puede que sea, tenga
relación con lo que contamos,
con lo que acabamos
diciendo en la obra,
este punto de maltrato a los
propios creadores y de hecho claro,
y al El Quijote incluso
lo maltratamos.
Es difícil de quererlo y de entender
que es un descubrimiento brutal.
Hay algo en esa ironía que está en
el Quijote que no está presente en
todas partes, y tendría que estar.
Es algo que es autóctono,
nos es propio.
Estaba Cervantes; era
uno de nosotros.
Y también su figura.
También la de un escritor que claro
a veces pues la hemos maltratado aun
siendo uno de los más
conocidos por el mundo.
Y bueno a veces estamos más
orgullosos de montar un Shakespeare,
que hacer algo sobre Cervantes.
Lo que ha sido bonito en este
proyecto es darle absolutamente la
vuelta y creo que es
un bonito homenaje.
Estamos todos felices
de este trabajo.
>> Gracias Jordi.
Por favor únanse para agradecer a
Jordi por esta charla tan amena.
Un gran aplauso.
Solo un pequeño anuncio.
Yo soy Catalina Gómez de la división
hispánica aquí de la biblioteca.
Y quería contarles que el próximo
viernes aquí en esta misma sala
tenemos otro evento en
honor a Miguel de Cervantes.
Un concierto, un recital
de guitarra clásica,
con el maestro Francesc
de Paula Soler.
Y también comenzamos ese día,
no el 15 de septiembre, perdón.
Nuestro mes de herencia hispana,
y tenemos alrededor de quince a
veinte eventos de toda clase de
conciertos, ponencias.
Así que los invito a que entren a
nuestra página web de la biblioteca
lco.gov y averigüen sobre nuestro
mes de herencia hispana y vengan
a acompañarnos.
Y por favor vayan a ver la
obra de teatro al teatro Gala.
Por favor.
Gracias
>> Jordi Casanovas: Muchas gracias.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.